Apple has invested
573 billion dollars into this over the
past 10 years can you guess what this is
maybe r d well Apple spends about six to
seven billion dollars per quarter on R D
so while that adds up to about 250
billion over a 10-year period that's
less than half of this other investment
maybe they spend it on Acquisitions well
Apple only has two Acquisitions that
even crossed the billion dollar Mark
beats and Intel smartphone modem
business but then if Apple didn't spend
this money on R D Acquisitions or
Investments where the hell did such a
ginormous amount of money go well it
turns out that Apple's biggest bet over
the past 10 years is actually stock
BuyBacks that's right Apple has spent
573 billion dollars over the past 10
years on stock BuyBacks